Hi everyone, my name is Sean Spitzer, Senior Instructor for Epic Games.
Today we're going to be talking about optimization for linear content, lighting and effects.
Some of the topics we'll be covering is lighting, optimization, analyzing scene and priority
areas, baking versus dynamic and overview.
We'll also take a look at Lumen and how to handle the key workflows, limitations, quality
control and optimizing and editing.
After then, we'll take a look at Lightmass Baking, CPU and GPU as a review as a whole
and we'll look at Lightmass Baking CPU as well as looking at setting up pre-computed
lighting scenarios and GPU Lightmass review.
Then we'll look at using Screen Space Global Lumenation, using some of the final pixel
workflows for that as well as ICVFX.
We'll look at ray tracing, optimizing for final pixel and ICVFX workflows and finally
we'll look at optimizing fog effects, what to look for and how to tackle those scenarios.
That's it for this one.
Hopefully you'll enjoy this course and have a great time.